لا تتوقف قوافل نقل المساعدات العسكريه
الى اوكرانيا ولا ينقطع التدفق مساعدات
انسانيه عبر شاحنات تنتظر طويلا عند
الحدود وصلنا الى اقصى جنوب شرق بولندا
هنا تقع حدود اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومع حلف النيتو وهو ما يفسر خشيه
البولنديين الدائمه من ان يصبحوا يوما خط
التماس الاول في المواجهه بين موسكو
والغرب الغرب دخل في تصعيد كلامي حاد ضد
روسيا حتى ان فرنسا اولت داعين الى الحوار
سابقا باتت تتحدث عن مواصله دعم اوكرانيا
حتى النصر اليوم
امر
الوقت الحاضر ومسانده بكل الوسائل الممكنه
ليوكرانيا حتى تدافع عن
نفسي نفسها نحن
اليوم مع اوكرانيا بكل وسايلنا حتى النصره
استرجاع اوكرانيا اراضيها المحتله استرجاع
سيادتها وسلامتها قبل عام دخل عبر هذه
الحدود الى بولندا حوالي تسعه ملايين لاجئ
اوكرانيا توزع معظمهم لاحقا على دول
اوروبيه مجاوره اليوم تراجعت اعداد
الهاربين من الحرب لكنها لم تتوقف بعد عام
على بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا ما زالت محطه
قطارات بشميشل هنا عند الجانب البول من
الحدود بين البلدين نقطه استراحه عابره
للاجئين الاوكرانيين قبل انطلاقهم نحو
وجهه جديده المئات منهم ينتظرون هنا منذ
ساعات بعد ان قدموا من مدينه ازابوريجيا
جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وهم ينتظرون هنا القطار
الذي
يستقلونه للوصول اولا الى العاصمه
البولنديه ومن هناك يتجهون نحو مدينه
هانوفر الالمانيه صور اللاجئين هنا تعكس
استمرار محنه الاوكرانيين وحاجاتهم الماسه
الى الاغاثه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
نقدم للاجئين دعما بالمعلومات ونساعدهم
للحصول على كل ما يحتاجون اليه من ايجاد
ماوى ووسيله نقل ونجيب على كل اسئلتهم الى
هذه المحطه الواقعه عند الحدود البولنديه
يصل يوميا من اوكرانيا حوالي الفيلاجئ
بدلا من عشرات الالاف يوميا قبل عام حسين
قنيبر العربيه من منطقه الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه